[Musica]
il mio ma ce l'ha e ti rimasto un po di
cibo non possiamo andare avanti così con
la casa sgangherata ma lentamente niente
non peschiamo niente ma qualcuno lo vede
il suo segnale maledetto dieci giorni
possiamo poi far niente la smetti di
fischiettare non sono io
sei tu ma un pazzo chi sta fischiettando
[Musica]
e tu chi con chi diavolo saresti
spiegami ragazzi ho visto segnale non è
che per caso per via dall'isola e
sarebbe un'idea sarebbe un'idea assisi
grassa nord ce n'è una enorme il gigante
poco bella bella
c'è un isola più grande di questa
ma e non come ci arriviamo a nuoto
impossibile un oceano spiega mi guarda
pescati da una barca una barca ma noi
siamo in due ce ne servono due e almeno
cos'hai da me piratesca perfetto passato
abbiamo scambiare le canne da pesca per
delle baracche va bene a tenga tenga
tenga prego bravo va bene ma lei ha una
barca per sé qualcosa del giorno di alta
misto schiantato quindi non ce l'ho più
però vi raggiungo vi raggiungo ai
partiti ragazzi tranquillizza quindi
raggiungono gli va bene andiamo
dobbiamo andare dritti dritti tutto va
bene se strada tuo pietro perché non mi
perdo io facilmente andiamo andiamo la
possiamo smettere di andare avanti basta
un'ora che andiamo avanti ma sai dove
stai andando ma perché si è cambiato
maglia l'ho perso il giubbino personali
per sel pu credo qualcosa vedo qualcosa
e questo e questo mi fa e che ne so e
non ci siamo pestati ci dovrebbe essere
questa massa o e gigantesca il confronto
a quella gavan prima ma è un sembra
terraferma più che isola dove da che
parte niamo poi ricominciare
un'insenatura teoricamente la vedi a
terra posso camminare in piedi due metri
senza arrivare dall'altra parte l'isola
incredibile mi sento come se fossi in
una metropoli aiuto apollo aiutami tu
hai capito niente una gallina mi ha
scassato tutta la barca però vabbè fatto
il nuovo bravo bravo bravo
adesso buttarlo per terra spaccagli il
figlio per terra spalla in figlio
spaccagli figlio luoghi baccaglini è
così hai fatto che lo si è infilato nel
deretano spacca lo spread a diventare io
spacco
[Musica]
ahia ahia non incominciamo va bene da
che parte andiamo uomo e non solo di
esplorare dobbiamo vedere come
quest'isola ebe e gigantesca come è
enorme ci sono cose che usava in attivo
ma quell'uomo misterioso tutto tutto
stupido l'abbiamo lasciato di là e ha
detto che sarebbe arrivato ma voti visto
partire no sai dove stai andando via
case case case eco case o civiltà sono
delle case o mio dio ma venne
saccheggiato tutto però assolutamente sì
dobbiamo fare la nostra parte il mio dio
sini cavalli ci sono esistono dei
cavalli minecraft villager va bene
allora facciamo così
chiediamo a questo buon uomo cosa ne
pensa vestita la salve mi ha detto che
mi da due di pane per uno smeraldo e le
fornaci ruba tutto ruba tutto prova
tutto a a porta secondo grado se la
sentì come poteva proprio la loro lingua
o mi ha risposto cosa mi ha risposto ho
capito bene va ma risposte circa un pò
in giro ci sono due smeraldi li ho
trovati nella cesta nella cesta di
solito io devo fare uno scambio però di
no e no perché il giorno e mi chiedeva
di smeraldi per fare uno scambio del
pane dei deficienti ruby le loro cose
poi le cose per fare scambi esatto
arrivando notte che lo facciamo
mettere qua in questi villaggi e gli
servirà un qualcosa per dormire
probabilmente no gli ho dato il pane
cavallo schifoso da mi fa ne ho fame e
non si fa neanche cavalcare st puledra
dopo che gli ho dato il padre ma che boy
o no adesso sentimenti questa selle tale
infine internet hanno giurato e vania
malizia povero cavallo questa maniera
gli ha baciato il pane ai fan è ovvio
che ormai aveva capito almeno fi cioè
già detto dalla magna cavalli sono
cattive persone scortesi per a milano
cavallo bianco
venite da tavola e ha dato un'altra data
un'altra 4600 bagnato fatti cavalcare
motto mag e zucchero e caffè un
cappuccino lo vuoi con lo zucchero senza
no no no no ai cavalli sono cattive
persone
ok ora il compito importante se in caso
ci mettiamo dormire ma che ne frega
hunter aria ma guai spaccato tutto per
terra
in questa come titola preso in un vuoto
da sinistra ma la smetti spaccare tutto
a posto fatto bella casa bella casa
nostra nostra amica civita qualcuno qua
non c'erano allora vieni le legno che in
legno amico
guardate siano arrivare a dormire porca
vacca dormiva quell essere che è
arrivato nella nostra isola vai
buonanotte perché devi dormire vicino a
me ma vai via maledizione vai via da
schifo o quell armi il posto ad ora o
giorno
buongiorno mi fa vedere un attivo come
stanno andando i tuazioni fuori sono
vivi loro come com'è andata la giornata
finale ho mai detto che ha pagato l'imu
l'altro giorno allora chi sei se il
prode amico rescue che abbiamo la
canzone che ci piace vent'anni voglio
fare le scampagnate voglio andare dove
viva e non fermarmi qua
questo viaggio mi porterà da tutti può
che girovagando col mio pietro io vi
lascio tutti indietro ei vedo un sacco
di roba da questo caso questa bomba l'ha
visto
c'è una frase quella roba lì vieni qua
per svecchiare mangia il pane e guarda
c'è una roba dico di ragnatele ci sono i
ragni pietro che schifo e quando te che
muammar sono essere qui dentro
di sicuro gente che ci farà un mazzo
tanto vediamo da controllare sì perché
sono pronto di euro
no magari no giorno a fare un pic
no no dammi la mano 4 metà vita mi ha
dato a me terminato una spada o quasi
morto distruggi il coso vedo niente
pietro aiuto ciò che hai anche se hai un
piano piano può dare aiuto visto che
incastravano le varianti a new york si è
fatto male sei morto
meno male una bella notizia prendi
prendi prendi le cose che so per terre
mi sono fatto malissimo in tutto questo
e chi non c'era anche il picco aia vasca
laida legnone male ma io c'è la fine di
stanotte è cosa vuoi che faccia io ok
che non possa spaccare lo spacco con la
spada
non voglio curatore non va con la spada
valeva e rompi le rompe il rompi lo
colpì con ci saranno delle ceste con
della loro dio è vero non scheletro
piano piano facciamo fuori è un clipper
la kleber è un twitter
in verità dovremmo tornarci da un po da
un po meglio che equipaggiati però
probabilmente ci sono delle ceste qua
ti prego dimmi che si era stata mente
quello che sperava una spada fortissima
bene già iniziamo a ragionare se avessi
una natura sarebbe meglio occhio
c'è uno che cavalca un ragno aiuto
amo sbraccia il sudore e non lo so è
forte vedo iniqua fermiamoci un secondo
riprendiamo attimo fiato e di colore
sono fermati anche due dischi che un
buco tutti qua vieni vieni ok perfetto
va anche ai oggi su amiche quindi questo
così adesso non dovremmo vertici di ok
pro tutto quanto ai qualcos'altro che
puoi darmi che ci hai alimentare
assolutamente no bene mola certa wake 4
ai cuori mancanti di ulteriori
fortunatamente abbiamo tratto st spada
che un po ci protegge minore protegge
sai una freccia nel cervello forse più
intelligente di primati toccatemi
inciderà po che non ci sono infatti mi
chiedi scusa un attimo da dove da che
parte delle due non so andiamo di qui no
guarda questa parte è uguale noto ma
niente pentito casino incredibile 3
fighissimo del genere mai risposto siamo
al casinò assurdo ok forse bravissimo
occhio se ci sono altre certo qua c'è un
spoilers perché ho visto benissimo ma è
così vai così siamo fortissimi
se non ci sta andando bene stia andando
bene l'allenamento è avverato infuocato
di mortacci tua è una freccia in testa
che ha fatto malissimo quanto si è
rimasto di vita ai a chiamare zero mi
dispiace non ti amiamo perché mi passi
davanti e non riesco ad allora un nuovo
atto quanto fa male dato aiutato
ma non sono la prendi prendo io grazie
devo continuare a difendersi andiamo
avanti e il teste di far qualcosa da
quella porta non ho capito la smetti di
passarmi davanti mentre picchio in un
fermo e iru firmo ma c'è una testa di
uno scheletro amico nino farina così
come ornamento usiamo questa possa
mettere in testa è vero c'è un'altra
festa miccoli a mia figlia e mia ora di
controllare vuota mi concentro non è
vero niente non c'è niente dai ecco lo
sapevo
giusto o gli stivali di prada sono forti
la protection quattro file protection 4
blas protection 4 kasami la caduta 4 e
un breaking 10 è immortale 6 immortale
un collaboratore di qua c'è un creeper
perché chiede sogni migliaia ma c'avrei
dei problemi ai neuroni che non hai più
mamma mia che problematico il clip è che
per sono moscati hanno bloccati pirla
anche se bloccato aspettassimo e volée a
quanto pare esplodono lo stesso scappa
via di qui cosa c'è non c'è niente tipo
di ieri sono presenti anche altri danni
o esposti per la mappa dei seguenti
occhio aperto progressimo saranno altri
dungeon soprattutto da trovare per
per trovare altri oggetti per diventare
quindi occhio mentre se poi c'è ancora
uno stoner questa spada fa i culi è
fuori di john aria aperta o altri dieci
pezzi di pane che sono ero morto
stecchito aspetto sei qua sono qui siamo
e saremo tagliamo non certi le uova per
vedere se c'è un pulcino non sono stato
io comunque dentro ho trovato 48 49 di
smeraldi e tre di diamanti miccoli elio
tratti nella cesta di prima però per
vinci pacco beringheli nadine di rim
bambolina i suoi brand le esatto faccia
male se facciamo un test di sono senza
armatura provata karmico la tua spa
dalle ore 3 cori e mezzo il fuoco
ahi ahi ahi ahi che male che è stato
bello fare questa promessa se ne
facciamo più no no no ho detto no va
bene allora idee di fare una cosa
andiamo dall'altra parte della montagna
finché ancora giorno
beh qualche non riesco a vedere il sole
non so per quanto riguarda giorno e
facciamoci una base da qualche parte ok
ora in cerca degli altri lancio ok ok
adesso vedo il tuo aquila falco stanno
portando gli hobbit isengard
[Musica]
69 suoi dove la facciamo questa casa
quindi isengard perfetto dove isengard
dove stanno portando perfetto la neve
tipi skyrim torri ei suoi la torre una
tragica è un altro lancio poleman tesi
probabilmente facciamo la casa prima
perché vediamo mai quindi andiamo qua
sotto
o c'è l'acqua perfetto e ora a casa
voglio voglio fare vicino anche
dell'acqua mi sento a mare esatti
stamani basta dungeon perfetto la vista
dungeon 0 proprio la spiaggetta è carino
9 è il primo legna quali casa raccogli
legna macolin ebbe
amico mi sa che ci dobbiamo muovere
perché questo diventando notte saliva
sono accorto se sì tanto eletti ore che
tranquillo che ho letto io ma io sono
ancora qualcosa cosa dello scheletro
veramente brutto grazie alla mattina ore
cos'è sta roba
ci abbiamo l'angolo cultura che ne so il
blog di blog dai costruisce permettere
detti poi visto che non ci basta forse
potrei ancora non è però questa beh
antiestetico ma può funzionare finita
però benissimo che mettiamo giù che
bella casa buono abbiamo tramite imposti
peggiori di questo e di lei che tipo di
fianco a te la vuoi smettere sito che fa
per morire mai compagnia di scheletri da
fuori senti che roba no no no no no no
basta aggiunge fastidio
io mi l'escape prison break parla
dell'affare si sono uscito a salve
l'hack è male agli occhi stato scritto
dal mare che dove il mare mare mare
scritto il mare dov'è il male
dov'è il martello dov'è il mare a
cavagna che schiaffo le rate uno
schiaffo a ieri girato alla testa
l'attrice sempre in francia conficcata
nel cranio il culo che aveva pronti
nella spalla nella spalla e la francia
nel ginocchio
vabbè comunque ceca ha dato ammazzato ma
tutti di uno schiaffo talmente forte
madonna o no te lo sei meritato cieli lo
sport la gallina adegui lo spot grazie
contraddico del tool è la mia milione ok
ma te la mia condividendo le cose da
venti episodi la mia maniera
perché io ho fatto una serie con un
individuo ai a port cala pure ci mancava
il grave rinfaccia già quello minghi
chiude uno del ferro nel ferro ferro del
ferro signori iniziamo a riprenderci un
pochettino di nostri materiali rovine io
comunque un 12 di oro risultato nella
roma di prima trottola miniera davvero
trovate ha trovato ha trovato ha trovato
ha trovato aveva altre un secondo figlio
arrivo
mi sa che un canyon sotterraneo
addirittura vero con dei rumori che non
mi piacciono per niente per andiamo
avanti con della gente che non piace per
niente però non andiamo avanti via via
via via da che parte arrivato non mi
ricordo più rappresentato da ridere ma i
jeans o basta basta saper che è successo
lì si è pagato tutto non vedo più la
torre te la sei magna da avevo fame
avevo
ascolta carica maledetto computer carica
o che bella la nostra torre andremo a
controllare sicuramente c'è un entrata
segreta secondo me là sotto c'è qualcosa
è veramente si sa però ragazzino
continueremo nel prossimo episodio
perché per adesso abbiamo raccolto un
sacco di materiale in cielo la cesta qua
non c'è la scelta e la faccio subito si
era grazie e mettiamo le casse sopra
altro detto vabbè ragazzi mentre che
cosa stai dicendo a parte quello è il
tuo ricordo
ciao antico neanche dove abbiamo dormire
mentre pietro mettere classiche possiamo
concludere quell'episodio spero che
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi nei
prossimi episodi andremo negli altri
dungeon e anche nella torre io proprio
video è sempre centrarsi cosa se vi
piace molto invece questo genere testa
in pietra descrizione non lo metto se
questi schiette decidiamo hanno
proceduto da ragazzi
metti di sotterrare beta yogurt o
aspetta aspetta aspetta ferma guarda un
pò bello primo secondo
ora facciamo un gioco bello ma è più a
destra
bravissimo fermo no no guarda un po che
sono spaccato pure cose no no no chi già
un cuore un cuore va bene
[Musica]